[Music]
[Siren sounds, ambulance speeds through the night. ]
[Intercom:] Dr. Robbins, Dr. Robbins, emergency.
Dr. Robbins, Dr. Robbins, Dr. Robbins.
[Health care workers accompany a stretcher with a patient on it down a hospital corridor.]
[Patient is rolled into Emergency Room and doors are closed.]
[The hands of the clock above the doors show time passing. The doors open.]
[Jerry:] Well, is she going to make it doctor?
[Dr. Robbins:] Hello, Jerry. Well, how's the
world's greatest newspaper man this morning?
[Jerry:] Okay doctor, I'm still looking for
news.
Say, about the youngster, is she going to be all right?
[Dr. Robbins:] Yes Jerry. No tragic ending
this time.
This little girl's going to get well, thanks to Dr. Hartley here.
[Dr. Hartley:] Well, you're too generous doctor.
The real lifesaving was done before she  got to the hospital.
[Jerry:] Well, I don't get it doctor. What's
the story?
[Dr. Hartley:] Here's what I mean, Jerry.
The real hero was somebody whose name you
and I will never know. The good samaritan
that gave that little girl first aid
at the scene of the accident.
[Dr. Robbins:] Yes Jerry, that person was
one in a thousand.
[Jerry:] Oh, but people always try to help.
That is, most of them do. Now, you can't expect--
[Dr. Robbins:] Yes, I know Jerry. Most people are willing to help, but that alone isn't enough.
It takes something more than just
willingness to save a life.
[Jerry:] Well, after all we can't all be doctors.
[Dr. Robbins:] Well, you don't have to be.
But, if everyone who is willing to help in
an accident or emergency were armed with just
a little, well, just the bare basic essentials
of first aid, a great many lives would be
saved.
If everyone...if you, and you, and you, and
you, would take the time to learn
what to do before the doctor arrived.
Know what to look for. Know what to do. Know
how to do it.
These are the essentials of first aid. Now,
let's see how these principles apply,
first in regard to wounds.
A sharp-edged knife, a broken bottle, a sharp
piece of metal, a shattered windshield...
they are but a few of the causes of wounds, wounds that bleed.
Bleeding can be fatal, but it can be stopped
effectively with simple first aid treatment.
There are two main types of bleeding that
can occur.
Bleeding from arteries and bleeding from veins.
To recognize each type you should know how
the blood circulates in the body.
The heart acts as a pumping station. The right
side of the heart pumps blood to the lungs.
In the lungs the blood picks up oxygen, which
is necessary to sustain life.
The blood then returns to the left side of
the heart, where it is pumped to all parts
of the body through a system of tubes known as arteries, then through a network of tiny
blood vessels called capillaries, and back
again to the heart through
another system of vessels, the veins.
When one of the arteries is cut, bleeding
is serious. Have you ever seen the way water
spurts from a hand pump? Well, that is the
way blood spurts from an artery
which has been cut.
Blood spurts with force from the wound each
time the heart beats.
This type of bleeding must be stopped quickly to save life.
In most cases bleeding can be stopped effectively
by simple first aid measures
such as pressure applied directly on the wound.
If this does not stop the bleeding apply finger
pressure, sometimes called digital pressure,
between the heart and the wound.
Another way is to use a tourniquet similarly
placed. Both methods compress and close off
the artery. In all cases of serious bleeding,
be sure to call the doctor.
To return to digital pressure -- there are
several points on each side of the body where
the arteries lie close to a bone. It's at
these points where pressure is most effective.
Arterial bleeding can be controlled on the
scalp and on the upper portion of the head
by finger pressure just in front of the middle
portion of the ear.
This stops the escape of blood from the arteries
serving this particular area.
Blood flowing from a cut artery in the lower
portion of the face may be controlled by pressure
on the underside of the jawbone, just in front
of the angle of the jaw.
This cuts off the supply of blood to this portion of the face.
Arterial bleeding from the neck can be controlled
by pressure on the bleeding side of the neck.
Anchor the thumb against the nape of the neck,
and with the fingers press alongside the windpipe
toward the spinal column.
Care must be taken not to press against the
windpipe.
For bleeding around the shoulder or armpit,
bend the head slightly toward the bleeding
side and bring firm pressure to bear with
the thumb behind the center of the collarbone.
The flow through this artery will thus be
effectively controlled.
Arterial bleeding of the arm at any point
below the armpit may be controlled by pressure
on the blood vessel against the bone of the
upper arm,
thus compressing the artery and checking the flow of blood.
If an artery is cut in the leg or thigh, bleeding
may be stopped by pressing firmly against
the thighbone high up on the inner side of
the thigh, thus shutting off the blood supply
to the limb below this point.
When bleeding from the arm or leg cannot be
controlled by digital pressure, use a tourniquet.
A triangular bandage rolled into a cravat
makes an excellent tourniquet, as does a
roller bandage, stockings, a large handkerchief, even a necktie will do if nothing else is available,
but never use anything such as
a wire or rope,
which may cut into the skin and cause injury.
When using a tourniquet, direct pressure on the artery is desirable. A small roll of bandage
or folded gauze is excellent for this purpose. Never use anything hard or with sharp edges.
Better to apply the tourniquet without a pad
at all.
Tuck the roll of bandage or pad directly over
the artery.
Wrap whatever material you are using for a tourniquet around the limb twice.
Tie a loose knot.
Place a short stick over this knot and tie it securely in place.
Now, turn the stick so that the tourniquet
tightens. Twist the stick only enough to stop
the bleeding. This causes the pad to press
firmly against the artery, forming a barrier
past which the blood cannot flow.
A tourniquet must be loosened at regular intervals
of 15 minutes to avoid permanent damage to
the tissues. If bleeding starts again, tighten
the tourniquet. Remember to loosen the tourniquet
every 15 minutes and tighten it again only
if bleeding resumes.
A condition known as shock may be present in all injuries and very frequently in severe bleeding.
If vital functions of the body are
slowed down, shock may result in death.
Therefore, while waiting for the doctor, treat
the victim for shock immediately after stopping the bleeding.
A person in shock is pale, has a cold clammy
skin, weak rapid pulse, and breathes irregularly.
Keep him quiet, lying down, warm him, wrap him completely in blankets
or a coat or anything to keep him warm.
Apply hot water bottles, carefully wrapped.
Bags of heated sand or salt.
Take care, though, that you don't overdo it and burn the injured.
Another thing to remember in treating shock
is position. Keep the body flat
and raise the foot of the bed, cot, or stretcher so the head is lower than the rest of the body.
If the injured is lying on something that
cannot be raised, keep his feet, legs, and thighs raised.
Keep him lying quietly and unless
he coughs up blood or has difficulty in breathing
or has a nosebleed, don't allow him to sit
up.
At this point, stimulants are important. One
of the most effective is aromatic squirts
of ammonia, one teaspoonful in one half glass
of water. Hot coffee or tea also are excellent
stimulants and are valuable in supplying heat.
If he is unconscious, never try to force him
to drink. An unconscious person may be revived
by using a stimulant, which can be inhaled,
such as ammonia inhalant
or aromatic squirts of ammonia on a handkerchief.
Simply hold the handkerchief near the nose
for a few seconds, or use smelling salts.
Shock may be avoided if these steps are taken in time.
So, those are the important things for you to do for a person suffering from shock.
Keep him warm. Keep him lying quietly on his back with his head lower than his feet
and give him stimulants.
Now, these things sound simple and they are,
but these simple first aid steps, taken before the doctor comes, have saved many a life.
Now, let's go back and take up the second
type of bleeding, a wound in which a vein is cut.
Now, here's the circulatory system again.
You have seen how the heart pumps blood through
the arteries to all parts of the body. However, on the return trip the blood flows back to
the heart through the other set of vessels,
the veins.
Remember how an arterial wound bleeds, spurting with a lot of pressure behind it.
A wound in which a vein is cut bleeds quite differently.
Blood escapes in a slow, steady stream, and with much less force.
The best way to stop this type of bleeding
is by direct pressure on the bleeding point
with a sterile dressing.
Dressings are usually made of gauze and are
available in various sizes so that any wound
large or small can be completely covered.
Because they come in direct contact with the
wound, dressings should be sterile.
That is, free of bacteria.
Sterile compresses are available in sealed
dustproof packages to prevent contamination.
The compress is placed directly over the wound
and should be large enough to cover the entire wound.
The bandage is applied to hold the compress in place.
There are a variety of bandages suitable for
all parts of the body.
A very useful bandage for first aid work is the triangular bandage, which is merely a 36 or 40 inch square of
cloth folded into a triangle or cut diagonally
into two triangles.
This can be used to hold a compress in place on the head, scalp, or face,
to hold large dressings in place as, for example, on the chest,
to place over injuries of the hand or a foot, to bandage the shoulder and upper
arm.
When folded as a cravat it can be used to
tie splints in place.
It can also be used as an arm sling, and of course as a tourniquet.
Do not apply a triangular bandage directly over a wound.
Many times a roller bandage may be used where
a triangular bandage is not available.
This type of bandage can be used to hold a sterile compress or dressing in place,
to hold splints in place, as a sling for the arm, and as a tourniquet.
Likewise, the roller bandage may be used in injuries to the arm,
to bandage an injured hand, in wounds of the leg, the ankle or foot,
to bandage the shoulder and chest, and in wounds of the head.
When using a roller bandage, hold it this
way and don't allow much of it to unroll at one time.
In this manner you will always have control of it.
Always keep in mind that any bandage should
be applied firmly enough to keep the compress
in place, yet not so tight that it tends to
stop the circulation of the blood.
For minor wounds, the adhesive compress bandage proves very convenient and it has many uses.
Be sure to remove the protective covering
from the adhesive ends and do not touch the
sterile gauze pad with the fingers.
There are other types of injuries, which also
require dressings and sometimes bandaging.
Among these are burns.  Searing steam, boiling water,
fire, a hot stove:
these are a few of the major causes of painful burns and scalds.
In the case of burns, there are several important
things to do: treat for shock, dress the burn,
and call for a doctor.
In severe burns, after treating for shock,
remove all loose clothing over the burn.
If any of the clothing sticks to the burned skin, cut around it, but don't tear it off.
Get medical attention at once.
If ordinary baking soda or bicarbonate of
soda is available, make a solution or a paste with tepid water.
If there is some water which
has already been boiled, use that.
Apply the solution or paste gently over the
burn.
Bandage very lightly and carefully.
If baking soda or any other approved burn
preparation is not available, cover burns
with a sterile dressing, bandage lightly,
and wait for the doctor.
Now, here are just a few don'ts. Try not to
break open a blister and
don't apply to a burn cotton, iodine, oils, or greases.
But first aid treatment isn't limited to
dressing a wound or a burn or stopping the
flow of blood. A person who knows first aid
can be of help in cases of unconsciousness.
An overturned canoe, a running engine behind
closed garage doors, a hissing gas jet,
a live electric wire, these tell what to look
for.
Now, if in such cases breathing has stopped,
the person may die,
but given artificial respiration immediately, his breathing may be restored and his life saved.
Now, here's the proper way to give artificial
respiration. Loosen tight clothing.
To roll him over, place one arm over his head, bend the other arm at the elbow,
and place the back of his hand beside his mouth.
Roll him so that his head comes to rest on
that hand. Turn his head upward so that the
nose and mouth are left free for breathing.
Make sure the mouth is clear and unobstructed.
Remove dental plates or any substances which
may restrict breathing.
If the tongue has fallen backward, pull it forward. Straddle the victim's thigh.
Now place the palms of your hands on the
victim's back.
Your fingers should follow the curve of the ribs, with the little finger right over the lowest rib.
Place your knees below his hip bone, so that when you lean forward, your shoulders are directly
over the small of his back. Be sure to assume a comfortable position.
Swing forward slowly and without bending your elbows, apply the weight of your body
gradually on the victim. This is step one of artificial respiration and should take about two seconds,
or the time you can count four--thus 1, 2,
3, 4.
Now, release the pressure by swinging back
away from the victim. This is step two.
This completes one cycle and should take about five seconds if done properly.
Artificial respiration should be given in
a continuous operation
and with the proper timing: 1, 2, 3, 4.
Remember the old song? Out goes the bad air,
in comes the good air.
Out goes the bad air, in comes the good air.
In some cases, it is well worthwhile to continue this treatment for several hours before giving up hope.
[Ticking clock sounds are heard as rescuer
continues administering artificial respiration.]
If you become tired, have someone else take over,
taking care that the rhythm is not interrupted or changed.
Watch the victim carefully when his natural breathing returns.
Recovery may be only temporary and he may again stop breathing.
When this happens, resume artificial respiration immediately.
Treat the victim for shock as soon as possible, and when he's breathing normally,
give him a stimulant and keep him lying quietly until the doctor arrives.
Now remember, in giving first aid to a person
whose breathing has stopped, start artificial
respiration promptly. Not too forcibly and
not too rapidly, but with a definite rhythm.
Call for an inhalator if available.
And now we come to fractures, broken bones,
a rickety or broken stepladder,
a carelessly placed toy, a bit of torn carpeting, stepping between parked cars.
These are but a few of the causes resulting in fractures of bones.
When a bone is broken, it may be either a simple or a compound fracture.
Now, here is the difference.
Here is an x-ray of a simple fracture. The
bone is broken, but the skin has not been pierced.
The area around the broken bone is usually quite tender and painful.
Within a short time, it'll become discolored and swollen.
Now, here is an x-ray of a compound fracture,
more serious than a simple fracture.
There is a connecting wound to the surface in the immediate vicinity of the break.
Bleeding may be severe. A tourniquet may be needed.
When you suspect a fracture, call a doctor
immediately, then treat the victim for shock
and make him comfortable,
and finally if he must be moved or if a doctor isn't available, apply a splint.
If it's a compound fracture, stop any bleeding and dress the wound and apply a splint as in simple fracture.
The purpose of a splint is to hold the limb
in a rigid position and prevent movement,
which might aggravate the injury.
An effective splint is a so-called fixed traction
type. A tourniquet is often placed around
the injured member, to be ready for use if
bleeding occurs.
For emergency purposes in the absence of a
traction splint, a board, rolled newspapers,
pillow, or umbrella may serve as a splint.
Regardless of the material used for splinting,
it should extend beyond the joints
above and below the fracture. If possible, it should also be wide enough to give adequate support.
Tie the splints securely, but not so tight
as to stop circulation of the blood.
Examine the injured part frequently, say, every 15 minutes.
If the injured part becomes too painful or
if circulation is being cut off,
loosen the ties around the splint.
Now, many times there is need of moving an injured person, either because a doctor isn't
available or because of the location of the
accident.
For instance, in the case of a victim who
has a fractured forearm, the transportation
problem is relatively simple. The forearm
should be splinted before the victim is moved.
However, the transportation of a victim with
a more serious fracture presents a greater problem.
In fact, the victim should not be
moved unless absolutely necessary
or under the advice of a doctor.
[ Horn blowing, little girl running down the
front walk of her house. ]
How many times have you read of a well-meaning motorist lifting an injured child from the street?
The very way the kind motorist lifts the child,
jackknifing the child into his car,
may cause broken ribs to act as jagged spears, which might easily puncture the internal organs.
Whenever there is a fracture of the lower
limbs or other serious fractures,
follow these simple rules. Only after a splint has been applied, use a stretcher.
A door or a wide board will do if a stretcher isn't available.
Place the victim carefully onto the stretcher, taking great care not to twist or jar the body.
Keep him lying flat. When carrying the
stretcher avoid unnecessary jarring or swinging,
which might aggravate the injury.
Remember, an injured person is at your mercy.
Treat them as gently and as kindly as you would like to be treated.
Well, you have seen some of the essentials of first aid.
Now, this doesn't make a doctor of you nor
a first aid expert, but a knowledge of
first aid should enable you with practice to relieve suffering and perhaps save a life.
When your opportunity will come or where it will be, nobody knows,
but your help may be wanted, may be needed at any time.
If you have not already done so, enroll for
a first aid course
and learn how to use your equipment properly.
Now always keep in mind these simple but important
rules to follow before the doctor arrives.
Know what to look for. Know what to do.
Know how to do it.
And when you call the doctor, don't forget
to give him some details as to the nature
or seriousness of the injury. And if you want to be a really good samaritan,
it's generally a pretty good idea to let the doctor know just where the injured person is.
[Music]